it's just before Christmas and the
people in the countryside near Moscow
are up early at least most of the men
are there off on a quest to bag the
perfect catch the famous Christmas fish
thank you all for coming we'll be
fishing over there in the pond let's go
competitive fishing is a popular
Christmas tradition here 40 anglers have
turned up today both young and old some
are old hands others beginners all that
matters is the trout in Soviet times
there was a fish processing factory here
but it closed down long ago but the fish
are still here much to the delight of
the villagers more the public butcher
great thing is that you can go anywhere
on the pond without a boat you can go
looking for the fish and for a bit of
happiness yes get where you're not sure
wish you little [ __ ] good quarter my
daughter is doing better than me I've
only just caught my first one
three and a half hours on the ice
waiting for a bite no one wants to give
up despite the freezing temperatures for
70 years under communist rule Christmas
was banned and people had to celebrate
in secret going fishing was not a
problem of course but going to church
was since the collapse of the Soviet
Union in 1991 the Orthodox Church has
seen a huge resurgence and now Christmas
is once again one of the most important
festivals in the Christian calendar much
of the celebrating takes place outside
in the community so how much does this
one way let's see look at that two point
six eight kilos Gennady Vladimirovich
takes first place with seven point nine
kilos in total congratulations
[Music]
there's Russian champagne for the winner
and plenty of Christmas cheer for all
the anglers